yes
we are live
and the rock is
[Music]
that flight was still there
oh who's that
star spangled
[Music]
and
[Music]
brave
ladies and gentlemen welcome back
july 4th july 5th edition of your
favorite podcast
this is
[Music]
my throat let me get it fixed but
anyways welcome back to ripping with
griffin
uh we're live it's july 5th i had such a
busy weekend i couldn't get the podcast
done i was in florida
so we're going to talk about all that so
we got nba finals preview
i got the the tomorrow war movie review
i want to talk about this [ __ ] with
rachel nichols what's going on over at
espn
but once again welcome back to riff and
with griffin
to get the mic ready
[Music]
yeah something on my throat y'all i'm
telling you i might have some polyps
some i gotta go check it out i've been
using this like you know like singer
spray and all this kind of stuff to see
because i do feel like there's something
when i'm in the shower i can't hit my
notes
so i know something's up anyways but
welcome to riffing with griffin live in
full effect thanks for being here
you know normally i get the podcast done
but i i was like in florida and then it
was just
oh man the internet at the hotel i was
at
was trash okay
and i just do not understand how you can
have trash
internet in 2021
so before i start with my [ __ ] and i
forgot i got to do my pre-roll
um this is supposed to be a pre-roll but
anyways welcome to riffing with griffin
and first off i want to give a shout out
to let me get this up and ready to go
shout out to helix sleep
helix sleep big shout out today to
healing sleep take their two minute
sleep quiz
and they'll match you to the mattress
that will give you the best
sleep of your life find your perfect
mattress at helixsleep.com
griffin love helix sleep so anyways guys
i was out in florida so let's talk about
two things let's
first let me do some bitching with
griffin like right up top
right up top we're gonna do some
bitching with griffin so i i um
all right first you're wondering why my
face is shaving while i look like a
crazy person but i'm just i'm so used to
like doing the look now but the first
time i did this i was like what
is up with my top lip like i don't even
have one
um but the um so i was uh
so i was shaving right so i'm getting
ready for the show you know what i mean
i'm in my room it's like 10 minutes i
got to get downstairs to the show
[ __ ] i'm shaving you know and then
like i had so i was just
trimming my beard like just tightening
it up and then i had to one guard on the
razor
and then as i'm going like this one
guard
flies off the razor and i go
so i had this stupid mark on my face
like you know this
low and so then i had to rage shave the
rest of my face
which really took me off so that's what
i did i raid shave the rest of my face
so that's why i'm clean shaving like
this right now
now the other thing though is like so
i'm at this hotel man
and i do not understand like i travel a
lot so sometimes you're at a hotel
and the internet is great and you're
like wow this is pretty good then
there's sometimes
you're at a hotel where you're like how
is this internet shitty
like my cell phone like the 5g tethering
like i don't know if you guys have 5g if
you have 5g i think most people do at
this point right now
but if you have 5g and you uh use it to
tether
man you're getting great broadband
connection man it's better than
broadband in some cases
like i use my cell phone sometimes when
i stream for twitch which is
you know make sure you check out eric
griffin gaming on
twitch i'm gonna be i'm doing that after
this that's twitch.tv
eric griffin gaming i need to have a
little thing for that up here i don't
have it yet but anyways
um i use my cell phone like i'm
literally using my cell phone to
play call of duty from my xbox
and it's great connection i'm on a
server playing with hundreds of people
and you know it doesn't there's no
latency nothing it's just great off the
cell phone
you ain't this hotel wi-fi like to me if
your hotel wi-fi
is cheap if it's [ __ ] you are actively
being cheap whoever the owner is of the
hotel because there is
no reason for shitty wi-fi
at this point okay none at all none
at all i do not understand it it's like
you're actively like you get
like what what little bit of money are
you saving
to not have the best wi-fi and what are
these wi-fi companies doing with the
hotels making them think they have good
wi-fi
like what kind of cheap [ __ ] is that
it's like come on guys
come on hotels stop messing around it's
20 21.
everybody's got laptops and cell phones
and ipads and then they bring in
multiple people with them
so you know you know there's like
sometimes two three people in a hotel
room maybe you got your family your kids
got their phones
there's no reason for to be where you
can't everybody get good wi-fi in a
hotel
it makes no sense
you know what i mean it makes zero sense
at all
you know so i don't know um but uh you
know thanks for being here guys i know
you guys are live
you know and i'm doing everything myself
so you know i got to go in and look in
the chat and there's idiots in the chat
so
hi all you good people in the chat the
rest of you you will get a timeout when
i look but
thanks for being here guys the chat so
if you see me looking over there i'm
looking at the chat for everybody
listening uh later
thanks for listening to griffin with
griffin so but yeah i just don't
understand how you can have cheap
internet in 2000 2021.
how are we having cheap internet in 2021
does it make any sense to you
don't make any sense to me so
that's my bitching about that and then i
was in florida and
man i don't i i totally get why
a large portion of the united states
population lives
in california that weather
in florida i just don't get it
it just doesn't seem like a place i
would want to be dealing with
on a regular basis it just feels like
a hot wet ball sack
is surrounding your body at all times
it's just moist you are moist
all the time and it's and then when
and then when it's hot you're hot and
moist it's just not a good feeling
i'm with the owner of the club we go to
breakfast and i go with nice weather
today he goes well it's probably gonna
rain i'm like what it looks beautiful
okay we walk into a restaurant takes me
to breakfast right
it's beautiful out i mean i'm telling
you beautiful
go inside this restaurant when we come
out it's a monsoon
okay monsoon outside like what is
happening
like to the point where i was ready to
build an ark and collect animals because
i thought this is some end of day
[ __ ] you know and everybody just you
don't even know what to wear
you walk out in florida like you can
have shorts and a t-shirt on
and then it feels right because you're
like man it's hot i'm sweaty
next thing you know torrential rain then
you're like do you need an umbrella
florida's the only place you walk
outside with a with a tank top and
shorts
and an umbrella and it's perfectly fine
like it just makes perfect sense so i
don't know about that weather in florida
so kudos to people that live in florida
that can deal with that and then
on top of that you have to always worry
about a hurricane
i don't know man i just get why people
live in california
because it's just the right amount of
dryness there's certain places in the
country where i just don't get why
people live there
coming from california i'm saying you
know i just don't get it
maybe i'm a california snob maybe i'm a
california weather snob
but i just don't get it
arizona is another place you go to
arizona and you go this is a hot
butthole
all the time like it's the kind of hot
where you just
like you go how did people settle here
they
at a certain point they had to feel this
heat when it's 100 degrees at noon
at midnight 100 degrees at midnight you
just go
oh man so you're always living with like
air conditioning
and then that can't be good for you
either so places like that so you go
arizona it's just hot as hell and then
you have places like alaska where it's
like below
30. you just go how what like you always
covered up
you know and then you have like places
like chicago you know you go to chicago
and there's like one time a year where
it's beautiful like it's like la
actually you know like
you know between 65 and 78 it's you know
and you're like oh wow it's like it's
like six days out of the year in chicago
where it feels like oh this is worth
living here
and then other times you're just like is
balls hot
or it's freezing and you're just like i
don't like changes of season now some
people like change of the season i don't
know about you
if the chat if you if you guys like
change of season
that's great but i just don't like
i don't like that i guess because i
guess i'm sport i've lived in los
angeles
my whole life so i just always i don't
even know we have sprunger here spring
and summer that's
it occasionally it rains and when it
does you know the place goes crazy even
if it's a drizzle we're like we're on
storm watch in california because it
drizzled you know
but like other places and i'm looking at
the chat right now and i totally agree
i would rather live in a super cold
place than a super hot place
because at least with cold you can do
something about it
like if you live in a really cold place
if it's cold you put on layers
you're sort of comfortable you find you
go inside it's you know
you have the heat on and you could get
the temperature down to like a
manageable place
but when is super balls hot man that
you can't do nothing because you don't
want to have your skin exposed because
then you're gonna you know you have to
put on spf 100 depending on how light
skin you are whatever your skin
situation is
heat cold overheat all day of the week
man
cold overheat but there are people out
here
who love that [ __ ] you know you know
then there's places like hawaii there
are some really nice places but even
like a place like montana
montana is nice it's beautiful it's
spread out i love montana
montana is a beautiful state until that
freaking snow starts man then that snow
and you're just like damn
you know it makes you feel like you have
to be i hate a place that you have to
feel
trapped inside and when it's extreme hot
extreme cold that's how i feel
you feel like you're just trapped inside
like what am i doing in here
all right so that's my bitching with
griffin
segment of uh the podcast now let's get
to uh
what i wanted to get into this week oh
griffin what graphic
first uh let's get into um wait we go
down here
i by myself had to miss miss q with wigs
so he couldn't make it over today but
uh today you know we talking about these
nba
the nba preview nba finals we got
the suns and the bucks
in the nba finals man sons and bucks nba
finals so here
here i am on nba.com you know so i don't
know uh
what they got going on on the website
for nba finals but you know so they got
the nba preview
came bucks clamped down on determined
chris paul so
you know um what do i think about uh
this nba finals um i think the nba
season was okay
i think that the playoffs were marred by
injuries i mean so many injuries man to
all the stars
you know would the lakers be in the
finals right now if if
anthony davis wasn't hurt who knows man
i don't it didn't look like to me that
the sons were going to be able to beat
the lakers but injuries are a part of it
it just so happens it's bad luck
i saw a stat that said like
statistically overall
injuries were down this year in the nba
i just think it's bad luck that all of
these particular stars are getting hurt
when they have to play so many times and
thank you for the super chat
super chat cc moon and but guys don't be
bashful hit them super chats i
appreciate it it helps support
the show um so i don't know man
like i don't know guys i don't know if
uh this was uh
a good season or not but these playoffs
is just you know you talk it's something
like
it's something like eight or nine
all-stars that got hurt
you know all my clippers kawhi got hurt
so to me
to me the clippers they were kawhi
leonard away from getting to the finals
okay they needed him they needed him you
know and so he got hurt and he was out
that sucked anthony davis
the lakers needed him um jamal murray
you you uh what you call it um denver
needed him
and then uh donovan mitchell in utah he
was hobbled he was injured
even though he's still trying to play he
was injured they needed him
uh you know the list goes on and on you
know you talk about in the east man
i mean the nets i mean look at the nets
i mean just they only played eight games
together because of injuries all year
and then you know you you didn't have
kauri irving again
i mean kawhi irving ah kawaii wow what a
great player that would be kawhi irving
kyrie irving uh didn't uh you know play
and they needed him i mean the nets
looked like they were going to demolish
the bucks
demolished them they were gonna demolish
them and then
everybody got hurt but it's part of the
game you know and so here we are with
and then the but look at the bucks the
bucks
see now the buck showed me something
with this because
i don't believe in the bucks i just
don't but
might have been the best thing for them
was giannis going down
against atlanta and it made these other
clowns get their [ __ ] together
man i think it really did i think um
what's his name drew holiday and middle
chris middleton
we're like you know what we're gonna
have to step up we're right
we're on the precipice of getting to the
championship let's not mess this up
and then brooke lopez had a baller game
i think this really galvanized them and
they look like their favorite to me
especially if giannis comes back
so i think that you know him going down
kind of like because last year he went
down and that team fell apart
i think this year they're like we're too
close to the finals let's not let this
happen again
thanks for the super chat um hawk man
appreciate that
um so here we are um you know
with the bucks and sons so my
initial assessment is bucks our favorite
because i think they have a better team
they have a better team they have a
better starting five
all right now let's go to the other side
the suns i said this a few episodes ago
i would like to see chris paul win the
championship
i really would uh i'm a chris paul fan
i think he's had a tremendous career
he's one of those people
that you look at and go he's one of the
top five point guards of all time he's
like you know he's respected he's just
one of those players that you know you
need a championship then people go
now it's different now he's up there you
talking about him isaiah thomas you're
talking about all the guys that have won
championships and you go
he's up there he deserves to be on that
point guard
round mount rushmore you know he's
starting to make that conversation and
who knows what they can even do next
year but
so i would like to see that i just don't
know that they have enough
can devin booker get like he has to be a
superstar
he got to be consistent it's got to be a
consistent play from devon booker for
them to win
and ayton he's just he just is
a monster right now so i give it up to
him for how he's playing
but i don't think that they have enough
unless those guys have
tremendous games you know just seven
tremendous games
to win the you know if it goes seven
games that probably means they didn't
have tremendous gains but there got to
be a level of
consistency for these guys to uh
to win so i don't know if giannis is
playing or not but at least he didn't
have any structural damage on that knee
so actually i think it's a more even
match-up you take giannis out
i think the bucks still they match up
well with them even still man
like you know you got drew holidays a
tremendous two-way perform
a defender and that guy's good man he's
good
he don't get enough credit for how good
he is i think that match up him and
booker
that's a that's a good match up and then
you got to see who's going to handle
chris milton i don't know
because the others on the other side
they don't have a better two-way player
to get offense and guard that guy
then you got you still got lopez he
might do that three-point [ __ ] keep
keep him out but he might have to bang
in the middle with eight and we'll see
if they cancel each other out or not
and then it's up to like what are the
rest of the players on the team
doing so we'll see that's my nba uh
finals preview
i want to stay in the nba because
somebody hit me up
on instagram and they said hey man you
should talk about this rachel nichols
situation because it's nuanced and as
soon as he said those words nuanced i
was like well let me look and see what
this
is thank you mike mike with the super
chat appreciate it
i um and so i looked up the situation
and i was like you know what
this is nuanced and i just and i love a
good
nuanced conversation okay
i love a good nuanced conversation about
stuff and this is like
from the new york times there's so many
articles about it if you don't know who
rachel nichols is she's the one on the
right you know and she's white
she's a white uh female uh performer
at on espn she does that nba show and
she's been around for a long time you
know she's actually respected she
first of all she works with a lot of
black people okay she works with a lot
of
ex-athletes and these people on her nba
show and
you know you've seen her around she's
like one of those faces where you go you
don't know her name but you go oh yeah
that's rachel nichols she's the one
that's always in you know
doing nba coverage all right so
so this story like i say it is very
nuanced
because on the surface when you look at
something your own personal feelings can
get involved and you have your own you
know it's like you know
it's like when you hear somebody say
something and then you skew it the way
you want to skew it
you might say like you might be like you
know whoever your personal experience is
you could be a person of color and be
like
that chick's racist that's what you
could say on the surface
but it's deeper than that and so as i
talk about this and as you're listening
i really want you to even if you have
know about the situation and you have
your own strong opinion about it
what i would like you to try to do right
now is divorce yourself
of your feelings of it i would like you
to try to
let's look at everyone's perspective and
see if it
you know we can see that this ain't just
an easy
thing to like easy things like you know
this is what it is we're just gonna
label it what it is
because i don't think it's that easy i
think there's a lot of different
layers and i think it's very nuanced
uh so that's the first now the first
part about it is okay so apparently
from what i've gathered from it is
rachel nichols was having a private
conversation
that was recorded all right
she was having a conversation and the
conversation was recorded
and then subsequently released which i
think is terrible
now in this private conversation she
says i wish maria taylor all the success
in the world
she covers football she covers
basketball if you need to give her more
things to do because you are feeling
pressure about your
crappy long time record on diversity
which by the way i know personally from
being
on the female side of it like go for it
just find it somewhere else
you're not going to find it from me or
taking my things
away all right
boom okay
i think that that is a fair
assessment okay so
let's talk about this for my first
problem with this
is this should not have been released
so whoever released it released it with
an agenda and
but it could go either way you know it
goes either way i i
i just i have a problem with how society
is right now
i have a problem with people
screenshotting dms i think that should
be like how
you can't record someone's conversation
and release that like that's supposed to
be illegal
you know what i mean like to me is this
legal you know you can't use it in court
i just think that there's something
really wrong with releasing private
correspondence with people
all right so bang it's done so you have
that it's done
because you know sometimes when you're
talking with somebody
you're talking with someone who
understands you you're talking with
someone who
they know because this lady she was also
talking with some of her colleagues that
i believe she was even talking to
someone of color you know i'm not i'm
not sure don't quote me on that i don't
know i don't know all the facts i really
should have like researched it more but
i'm not a research podcast this is just
me
giving you my opinions on things you
know what i mean uh
um you know anyways so
she's having this conversation and
sometimes you're having a conversation
with somebody that you like they know
you
you know so they you know they you know
it's like you don't have to preface
with your friends or our colleague if
they know you and you're this
comfortable talking about stuff
like i don't have to talk like like she
doesn't have to say
to this person she's talking to by the
way i'm not racist this is just how i
feel about this for me
she don't gotta preface her conversation
with this private conversation she's
having
but someone else listening to it might
be like oh here's a white woman talking
about a black woman
or how racist is that okay
you know that's why i'm saying divorce
yourself of your opinions
and see how we could
just think about this for a second from
her perspective so here she is
this white woman just first of all woman
working at espn and you want to talk
about where toxic
masculinity not that i have anything
necessarily wrong with that like i'm
tired of people using those words to
like make like how
to make men seem evil oh talk no that's
just some term they use for like
being a man you know what i mean like
when you're around man stuff you know
it's like sports it's very masculine
it's very
a type personality it's a it's it's also
a meritocracy where the best
whoever the best is is going to be shiny
no matter what their race or
what their race or color you know you
know or whatever their
whatever sexual orientation none of that
stuff even matters when it comes to
sports because
if you're the best if lebron james was
gay
you know what i mean we would be like we
would be going it wouldn't it wouldn't
even matter we wouldn't even care
because he'd
be the best basketball player right so
we don't care about that kind of stuff
when it comes to sports
we can talk smack about it but we don't
care when in terms of like when we're
watching we're like well that guy's the
best
even racist people watch basketball and
even they might say like
man them you know n words can jump but
they still watching because they can
respect the talent all right so sports
is all about that
which i like um you know so here she is
this woman
trying to make it in a man's world and
she did
she's got this hit nba show
she's been around the finals she's been
around all these things she's one of the
few women that work at the network
she just happens to be white but she's
like yo i deserve
this shot like i've been in the trenches
okay that's what she's talking about
she's talking about like
regardless of who's getting the job
she's saying
my credits i deserve it
don't take away from me because i'm
white
don't and i'm sure that's a lot of
sentiment that that's a sentiment that a
lot of white people feel
you could be a good [ __ ] you could be
a good god-fearing white person right
now
who doesn't have a racist bone in your
body
and you are qualified and you are
working hard and you feel
like you are working for a job and you
want it and then
the company that you work at has a
terrible track record of diversity has a
terrible track
record of gender equality and then they
go
they give the job to someone and you go
i'm more qualified than that person
but the people from the outside looking
in are making it about oh
you think you're more qualified than
that person because of that person's
gender or color or race
and not uh that ain't what it it's about
it's about you feeling i'm qualified
look at my damn resume my resume
shows i should be getting this job why
are you taking this away from me
boom and if you go and if you think this
other person is qualified
take away some of the other people you
still got white guys there working
there's going to be white guys at the
finals you know there's going to be
athletes at the finals who are all their
only qualification is
their ex-athlete take away from them why
does it have to be
the two females have to go after each
other why does it have to be that
you know so that is like
one so that's when you look at it from
just rachel nichols perspective
i don't think she was bad-mouthing this
woman i don't think she was badmouthing
maria taylor i just don't
i don't think she was badmouthing her i
think she was saying yo
what my qualifications i am qualified
for this you know what i mean i'm
qualified for this
you know so i think that that was like
um
you know i think that was what this was
ultimately
about you know i think that's what this
was ultimately about for her
her perspective on it just a second guys
i got a uh
i gotta ban somebody from my chat uh
guy's a real [ __ ] so he's got to go
and this is what happens
you know what i mean
[Laughter]
uh so now he's hidden good riddance
uh go someplace where somebody cares
about what you think because it's not
here
anyways so um
that's that perspective there so you
have her side of it
she's and then i think that she's also
pointing out that
yo this company i work for
is toxic we've had so much
problems with diversity and gender
equality within this company
and now all of a sudden now because the
world is looking
got their eyes on it you do this sort of
transparent move
where people you know you think that
that's easing the uh
the the things that people feel about
the company i think espn has a problem
and she's pointing that out
it just so happens that maria tails on
another side now you look at maria
taylor's side she's like
yo i'm doing my thing too i'm qualified
i've been working hard and you want to
talk about inequality and diversity
she's like not only am i a woman in a
man's world i'm also
black woman so you add that on top of
that and she's like yo
i'm working hard too i deserve this too
and so it just sucks that the company
seems to be
pitting them against each other because
of how they made this choice
and i completely understand
from my own perspective and i'll give
you some my own personal
antidote for this this is what's
happening in comedy
listen man i'm a person of color not
only am i a person of color i'm not a
i'm not a looker i'm not one of these
handsome comedians
you know what i mean i gotta be funny
when i get off stage nobody's going he's
hot because that's what you hear a lot
there are certain comics that i hear
women in the in the uh
in the hallway after the show i've heard
this not
no exaggeration a comic has gotten off
stage and i and i i hear the girls
talking about them
and the first thing they say oh that
guy's hot he's so hot
i never get that i always got to get
he's funny
oh that guy's funny so so i'm fighting
that
and then i'm fighting being a minority
i'm also fighting being like an
ambiguous minority you know so that's
been my struggle
even just at the comedy store just it
can't be explained specifically when i
was first coming up
it was very white it's still very white
it's still a lot of white comics a lot
of white male comics
and now a lot of white female comics
it's very white at the comedy store okay
so me trying to make it in that
environment
it wasn't easy i had to bust my ass to
get what i got
now we're living in this society where
dumb asses like to tweet at the lineup
they
they see the lineup and then they tweet
oh there's no
females on the lineup where the female
comics how come there's no female
comics you know and i'm my and my [ __ ]
is like yeah
uh take another look it's still mostly
white so you want to take away so
don't lump me in with your male you know
your male hate
oh it's another male oh it's another
male it's like yo
yo yo yo i had to bust my ass to get
here so whoever you are
bust your ass to get there but don't
don't lump me in
like i'm the same you think i could just
call the place and be like
yo i'm a male put me on the lineup it
don't work like that i know you want it
to
i know you want to think it works like
that but it doesn't work like
that it's more nuanced than that and i
don't appreciate being lumped in and
having [ __ ] taken away from me
because you know you know it's like what
is the diversity going to be so we're
going to have six white women on the
lineup is that going to be the diversity
because then where's everyone else
where's the black women where's the
asians where's because
it'll never stop we have to stop asian
hate so now it's like well we gotta put
asians on the line up we gotta put you
know
you know you know what i mean at a
certain point comedy's got to be like
sports it's got to be a meritocracy you
know we got to make it where
the funniest the people that sell the
most tickets the people that like
all these factors go into it the people
people want to watch people that they
come to see
it has to be about that and these people
don't
they don't think that you think you
could just put hey let's just have an
all-female lineup and you think people
are going to come watch that
no they're not and it's not because
they're female it could be because they
don't know who these people are
you know if you had a lineup of like
whitney cummings eliza schlesinger and
ali wong and you had a lineup of people
that work all the time that are super
successful
that are super funny these people that
people know yeah the lineup's gonna be
thick they're working these people that
that these the female comics that are
like in
the at the comedy store they work all
the time they're always working
and when they come there they get spots
it's these other ones that think
oh we're just going to put this person
who hasn't been doing comedy a long time
we're just going to put her up and we'll
see because people are going to be like
well i want to go see them just because
of this
it don't work like that you still got to
be funny you still have to have
something
some charisma something so it's like
it's more than just people don't go to
comedy shows because of race gender or
sexual orientation
unless you make it about that you know
unless you make it where it's like
the gay show the asian show the urban
night
then then it'd be then you think it
because then you've made it about that
as opposed to
you know making it about these are the
funniest most famous people
uh that's why people want to come see
him it's a tough sell in la
so anyways again it's more nuanced you
know
it's really it really is it's you it's
not just about that
it's not just about and listen and while
i agree
it's a very masculine world even in
comedy and the same thing with probably
espn there are a lot of very funny
female comedians that i that are not
getting the shots that they deserve
so we need to change the overall culture
of comedy and the same thing
at espn they need to change their
overall culture
but they've made it where it seems as if
they're they go well let's look at this
spot okay well we can only put one
female so let's just pick one
as opposed to like maybe these two are
the best for the position
so they both should be working there and
you need to take away one of these
schlubs
maybe that maybe that's what they need
to look at but because the culture is
not
set yet because we're not at that place
where
we can actually look at something with
common sense and just
and look at it with an approach of like
okay who's the best for the situation is
this going to be
this going to work for us if we do this
as opposed to doing it because of some
reactionary reason
being reactionary to like people are now
giving you heat
the fact that people are giving you heat
is proof that you haven't been doing
this [ __ ] right
in the first place the fact that this is
happening so
my overall wish here is don't attack
rachel nichols
all right don't attack maria taylor
because she also is busting her ass
don't attack them
for having an opinion about this job
that they're going for their livelihood
it's more nuanced and you have to look
at the overall picture
and see that this has to do with
this company espn it has to do with the
culture that is
and these are the results of that
this is the results of why this stuff
is happening and i hope that you can i
we need to really start looking at
things like this people are so
like i'm telling you sometimes people
write comments and the people that write
comments
i mean legit you're an idiot
like i'm telling you like some of these
comments people write
they you don't delve deep enough
into say what i'm saying right now
like if you attack me for talking about
this
then you're not paying attention because
i'm not
faulting any one particular person in
particular
i'm talking about like the causes of why
this is happening
you know it's like if anybody if anybody
i'm attacking it's actually the culture
at espn
that's what they've built and they can't
change it if they want to they can
change it
but that's really the root issue like
attacking me
for your clout you know that's all that
it is or to get a response out of me
if that's your thing it's like you're
wasting your time you're wasting your
time and energy let's have discussions
man
let's discuss things i don't care if you
disagree with me
even if you're somebody out there that
is like if you're a person of color and
you want to hit it with uh rachel
nichols is racist
let's discuss it really think about it
because really do you think that's the
issue and why
or if you're bringing up the past you're
bringing up something from the past like
here's a behavior a pattern of behavior
and here we go again
white society is doing blah blah you
know don't use the past to
it's not always what it is it's case by
case and i think that she
was when she was reaching out to people
of color too by the way she was
it was like lebron's people uh believe
that she was talking to she
she's reaching out to people just to be
like yo like this sucks
right don't you think this sucks because
it's probably hard for some white people
now
to talk about this it's hard for them to
be like hey
without somebody going oh you're a
racist you know you've had enough white
people get it all why are you you know
so sorry you didn't get this one and
that's a fair
feeling okay that's what i'm saying too
when you're discussing stuff
it's a fair feeling to
[Music]
it's you know you know i mean to want to
because of the wrongs that you feel have
been going on
and that's what i'm saying try to
divorce yourself of the your emotions
try to divorce yourself of your own
personal
experiences too and i don't even know am
i doing that if you think about it
because my experience with the comedy
store
i'm trying i'm trying to divorce myself
with the feelings but i know i have
those feelings and this is why i'm
trying to this is why i'm talking in
defense of rachel nichols
and maria taylor because like i say she
deserves the work too
and it sucks here's a sucky part about
it too all right let's go on more on her
side right now too
the sucky part about it is and here's a
real world example
remember the movie moonlight that was
on the heels of oscars so white
so because you had oscar so white here
you have this
great well-made movie it wins
oscar so white took away from
moonlight's win
because because of that we were going
well
that movie won because of this not for
the merits
of that great movie thank you honest
dave this is the same thing
with maria taylor
so because of the talks because of this
lack of diversity at espn
and people getting on their case about
it this
super qualified person now
gets told you only got this job
because you're black and a woman how
sucky is
that that's why it starts with
the culture at the company and how to
change
that this is the first step so there are
some people that can argue
hey to fight that here's what we have to
do
we have to start hiring people so in the
beginning parts of it
it's going to feel weird it's going to
suck there's going to be people like
rachel nichols who are going to feel
cheated
but the only way to combat this the only
way to change the behavior
is to now we have to hire but it can't
just be one
you have to see a sweeping change it has
to be like let's get the most qualified
people
and then we'll deal with it then you
stand by it
because they should support her
they should support her the person that
they hired they should come out and be
like yo
this is insulting she's super qualified
and this is why we hired her
you know and but right now because of
their own behavior
their own history where
these two women are now put in this
situation and i think
that that sucks you know what i mean
all right well that's enough with that
uh
chat how you doing
[Laughter]
all right so let's take some time right
now to uh
revisit our sponsor
ladies and gentlemen helix sleep helix
sleep
um i have a healy sleep mattress and i'm
telling you right now it is the most
comfortable mattress
i've ever slept on i didn't realize how
important your mattress is
in terms of how your body feels like if
your back is hurting
uh like especially what kind of sleeper
are you or a side sleeper a stomach
sleeper
a back sleeper it really does make a
difference what kind of mattress you
sleep on
you may not think so it's the kind of
thing you don't think about
but it is super important and helix
sleep is here to help you and so i
highly endorse them because
i have one i'm not just saying this
because there it adds
i am saying it because of that and i'm
saying it because it's
it's healthy you know what i mean not
being able to sleep is a big thing too
politics anxiety stress your love life
who knows what it is
having a good mattress to help you sleep
is so important
now the big thing about healing sleep is
they have this great sleep quiz you take
the two-minute quiz to complete
and it matches your body type to the
best mattress that they have
i love that it's like i always say it's
like e-harmony for your uh
for your body and your mattress you know
tinder for your mattress man get the
right mattress and you swipe right on
the one that you want
uh helix is awesome but you don't need
to take my word for it all right please
take this limited two minute sleep quiz
helix was awarded the number one best
overall mattress pick of 2020
by gq and wired magazine just go to
helixsleep.com
griffin take the two minute sleep quiz
and they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life
helix is offering up to 200 off
all mattress orders and two free pillows
for our listeners to
helixsleep.com
griffin they have a 10 year warranty and
you get to try it out for 100 nights
risk free they'll even pick it up for
you if you don't love it for free
but i guarantee you you will love it so
go to helixleep.com
griffin use my code get a good mattress
and
i'm telling you right now you will not
regret it all right look at me doing
live ads um
yeah i know that i see the chat talking
about what i was talking about before
yeah rachel nichols has been around man
it's her job you know you know anyways
let's go on to something else now guys
uh i saw this movie on um
on amazon and i want to talk about it i
i do
i do recommend it it's called the
the tomorrow world war with chris pratt
tomorrow world war you know uh
there's that one check from um um
handmaid's tales in it
sam richardson who was dope he's the
great like
comic relief non-hero hero so shout out
to him
uh i love seeing comedians do this kind
of stuff because it's like yes
that means it's like it opens up the
door for me right
i want to be in an action movie but it
was really it was an interesting movie
okay so this is spoiler alert time right
now
if you haven't seen it but i do uh i do
i recommend it let me start with that i
recommend it so if you don't want to
watch and hear me talk about the movie
right now
uh you know it's it's time for you to to
move on but
there it is right there it's a thrilling
side science fiction action adventure
the tomorrow war the worlds is stunned
when a group of time
travelers arrive from the year 2051 to
deliver an
urgent message 30 years in the future
mankind is losing a global war
against a deadly alien species all right
so they figured out time travel and
they're sending people back
okay so first now usually with time
travel
the movie science if it don't make sense
to you
if it's too confusing then you're out
you know you check out on it i actually
really enjoyed
the time travel science in this movie
so it was like 30 years in the future so
so somebody asked in a movie which was a
great question like why don't we just
travel back to the beginning of the
the war and then stop it there you know
and it's and they're saying the movie
well it doesn't work like that
you could travel back and forth but time
still moves forward
and i was like ooh i love that it makes
sense so like
you know so if this is one point in time
and this is another point in time
and they're saying time still moves like
this no matter what
so you can't go back because time's
still moving you're still
from this point to that point it's 30
years in this wormhole
and i loved that i was like that made
sense to me i was like okay i love the
time travel stuff so i i didn't have to
like
[ __ ] on the time travel part because
that's usually what happens when you
watch these movies
chris pratt was great as usual
let me tell you who chris pratt is chris
pratt is
if bruce willis and arnold
schwarzenegger had a baby
that's chris pratt because he's got that
lovable dad
superhero thing where it's like the
regular dad guy is doing the impossible
and he's got he's in great shape and he
looks like an action star
he's got that and that's what happens
when you combine someone who has real
comedic talent
and then they have that like you know
good physique so
i i really enjoyed it now i see somebody
talking about this is a edge of tomorrow
it's not edge of tomorrow is not the
same it's not
i know it feels like that because it's
got the word tomorrow in the title
but that wasn't even the original title
of that movie it's not that that and i
love that tom cruise movie that uh i
really loved it but this is not the same
it's not at all all right so um
so chris pratt i love chris pratt uh in
this he's great and i thought the cast
is great
but i do have some problems with the
movie
i have big problems with the ending like
i just have problems with the ending
the science of the ending like what they
did to
like solve the issue there was this big
explosion whatever they were doing you
know they went to russia you know all
this
i didn't like that you know what i mean
like if you saw the movie you'll know
what i'm talking about it was like
they found them too easy that's all i
say i won't do too much of a spoiler
but i was like no way they found them
just like that you know i thought that
was like
lazy but overall you know it's about a
father and his family and it's like it's
a real good like family story too
because
he had this issue with his father played
by jk simmons and like you know men have
their thing well this is why i left my
family
and they have some justified reason why
they did it you know
and then he comes to find out that you
know he comes to find out through the
story that he might have made a similar
a similar choice and
it's about forgiveness and it's about
like you know
it's about like re-prioritizing what you
think is important in your life so there
was a lot of good
messages in the movie along with having
some great action
i think that the monsters one thing as a
negative for me is like the monsters and
the aliens in the movie they seem to be
way
more powerful than you know than what
they were
actually doing like i just didn't
believe that
these humans could fight off so many
aliens you know
an example is like look i'm kind of
rtfartie when it comes to suspending my
disbelief in a movie
i want to suspend my disbelief so when i
see something i need to believe that
this is possible
and i can't start poking holes with my
analytical brain because i'm a comic
so when i look at something i always
over analyze because i see where can i
make a joke out of this
so if i'm analyzing and i see some holes
i'm gonna give you an example from a
different movie
so the last star wars movie that came
out uh return of skywalker or whichever
one it is
you know my biggest problem in that
movie is
how the [ __ ] is the empire building a
thousand ships
like if they can build a thousand ships
they should have already won
they should have already conquered the
universe why are there so many ships
and where did they make these ships
where'd they get the metal from to make
these ships where are they getting the
power to make these ships
so you're just holding on to all these
ships in some secret part of the
universe when you could just dominate
right now
you could just send like four ships how
many ships does it take to take over a
planet
you just take four ships you start
shooting lasers at the earth
at the ground and you send them a
message yo we're taking over
you know you know it don't make any
sense it just
every time i saw that i go oh they got
this much money and resources
where are they getting these resources
for to make all these ships
and why are they hiding in the outskirts
of the universe it made
zero sense to me so i couldn't suspend
my disbelief
it's the same thing in this movie with
these aliens they just seem to be
it seems to me that one alien could
erect
all of them but there's like 50
60 running through the streets coming at
them they're these huge monsters that
are shooting spikes
i was like wow this looks very
formidable
i don't think these people could do what
they're doing that's just
what i thought about it and they made
the aliens so powerful like you could
only kill them in the bellies in the
neck
you know what i mean and then they're
recruiting regular people that so that
in the movie they're
drafting people and they're sending them
back in time to try to fight this war
so so people don't get instinct either
so the you know people don't
freaking die so i don't know
um it's still a good story
there's still it's still a good story um
i really enjoyed it uh
you know but like there are some things
where you go i don't know if that's
possible but you just kind of just shake
it off and be like well let me just
enjoy this movie because
the performances were good it's funny
where it needs to be funny and i saw a
bunch of comics in it you know
mary from marriott is never i can never
say her last name properly but she's in
it
and uh you know she's from the comments
she's like a great comic she was on 24
and i was in the here she was also in
hero mode you know
she's she's like she was like green and
she had this great you know
badass scene and i loved it i was like
oh [ __ ] good for you girl
uh mary lynn you know let's go to
i'll show you right now mary lynn was in
it and a shout out to her i
i got to get her on the podcast but you
know she was in it
you know and it was like it was so dope
to see her
be in this movie and she was like a
badass in the movie so shout out to mary
lynn right there
um you know so that was dope
to see when you see your friends in a
movie like that and they're being a
badass i love it
you know i mean so um yeah so
kudos shout out to mary lynn and
the people that made this movie i think
they did a good job and it's worth
seeing and it's on amazon so if you have
amazon prime go take a look at it
you know what i mean and make sure you
check me out on twitch i do stream
you know what i was gonna end with with
that but i i gotta tell you guys about
this bruce willis movie that i saw on
the plane
man i don't know what bruce willis
situation is right now
but i gotta tell you man this dude is in
a ton of really shitty movies dude
um i gotta look on this imdb to get to
even get the name of this movie
it was on the i saw it on the plane
right you know and
i dude i don't know
like if you go like just search bruce
willis on netflix y'all
and you will be surprised at how many
movies he's in
that you've literally never heard of
before
like i'm looking at his imdb right now
you know
oh he's got he's doing another die hard
okay
there's one called the fortress hair of
the dog paradise city
white elephant die like lovers like
he's in so many movies
oh i see it right here dude here it is
right here so i'm on the plane
i'm on my united flight and this movie
comes up
okay it's called
cosmic sin oh
my god guys
this is the shittiest movie
oh man you gotta watch it just
to see like everything
about this movie was terrible
i mean i'm on i'm watching it for
free and i turned it off
i got like three quarters in and i
couldn't believe the performances
like i get it it's low budget
you got bruce willis he was probably
being a monster on set
just from like i'm bruce willis it's
like
you watch a movie and being a performer
and being have been in movies
i know what it takes when i'm saying i
know when you see something bad i know
why it's bad
for sure they only did like one or two
takes of every scene
for sure they were like we got it let's
move on do you know what it take like
i'll give you an example you watching
workaholics man workaholics
i've told this story before but i'll
tell it again about this kyle
on work of hogs you know last season of
workaholics
i'm doing i'm dying up here and he sees
the show and he hits me up he's like yo
man you've really grown as a performer
and i took offense because i was
shooting these shows at the same time
like yo bro i didn't go to acting school
for six years and then did i'm dying up
here
i was already that guy you just don't
use me like that
this other show did i'm dying up here
was a drama we did like five six seven
eight takes we did different angles
i got so many chances to get it right
and do it right on workaholics let me
tell you how i went
if i'm doing a scene with the boys with
adam blake and anders i'm doing a scene
with them
the camera's behind me shooting them it
was like this
single on adam single on blake single on
anders double on adam and blake
uh y coverage swingle uh single on them
i'm talking about 20 takes so these
three could get it right
turn it around on montez two takes we're
out
two takes three takes tops got it moving
on
that's how that's how you get shitty
work
that's how shitty work happens and i
guarantee you on this cosmis
cosmic sin that's how they did it it was
like
let's get this done we got three weeks
to get this done we only got bruce
willis for like 10 days we got to do the
whole movie
i bet you with some [ __ ] like that man
and and you know what you get [ __ ] work
when you do it like that
you know that's that's how that that's
how shitty it is
that i know that that's what it was so
anytime you watch a movie and you wonder
like
how did they why did they use that take
of that person
like you didn't believe the person or
you thought like that person wasn't
being a good actor
i'm telling you it was in the creation
of the show or movie
they only did like two three four takes
maybe four at the top and they went we
got it moving on
because they needed to get the [ __ ] done
and that's what happens you know
just lucky for me even when i'm doing
workaholics you know i just i'm a funny
guy so i'm a stand-up comic
so like i'm funny you know what i mean
so it was easy to be montez and just
have big moments and be funny but
sometimes there were many times
when filming workaholics that i wanted
to do it three or four more times
trust me i wanted to do it differently
and see if i could really get it
get it in but you know
they they didn't allow that man they
didn't allow it
at all so it is it is what it is but i
don't know why i
i had to talk about that movie because
i'm telling you right now
that movie is terrible
and you know who's another one samuel
jackson sam
sam jackson and bruce willis man you
look at their imdb and you check out
some of these movies you'd be like
why is bruce willis in this movie that
was my first thought when i saw this i
was like why is he in this movie
what is going on so i don't know man
oh yeah oh did i ever somebody in the
chat just asked me did i ever ask for
more takes oh yeah dude this became a
running joke
bill bill and i we our running joke was
we would be like let's over
over under on how many takes we're gonna
get right now they did it on purpose
i'm telling you they would also wait my
coverage would be the last thing they
shoot too
it's like we're about to go and they'd
be like all right let's turn around on
montez
i'd be like okay do we get it it's like
we got it good job man moving on i would
be like can we do it again
trust me i would ask about this all the
time but they got you you got it you're
good man that was great
that's how they did it so don't come at
me later talking about oh you've really
grown as a performer
yeah you mean when i only get two times
to do it
so i had to be an expert in those two as
opposed to like these [ __ ] get like
17 takes
[Laughter]
monsters all of them all three of them
are monsters
oh man
all right guys but anyways i really
appreciate you guys being here
uh for riffing with griffin i did it
live this week because i had quite the
weekend it was hard to get everything
together
you know but we did it um
i appreciate all the super chats i
appreciate all the interaction in the
chat
but please subscribe share
help pump my podcast out um and
you know i don't say this enough but i
do really appreciate
all of the people that come to the
podcast every week
i appreciate the the messages i get you
know we're small
we're mighty and i'm gonna keep doing it
and i really like i say
i got some dates coming up so make sure
you check out my website eric
griffin.com which i'm working on really
believe me i'm working on it currently
to make the website better
but go to the schedule section you can
see the dates that i got coming up and i
might be coming to a city near you
so come out and check me out um and yeah
that's all we're gonna do uh i
appreciate you watching griffin
with griffin and i will see you next
week
peace